he's the most entertaining 135 in the
world they got him ranked at number 12
finally but he's number one in your
hearts we flew him all the way from
arizona to calabasas california it's
sugar shawn on this week's food truck
diaries and i'm feeding them mexican
food let's go
super thick from my wallet to my check i
don't want it if it's skinny but i need
it if it's thick
need a thick girl
for the
[Music]
got a little bit of a brace on that
right hand the money maker some would
say i know i always get made fun of
because i supposedly get hurt after
every fight but i don't think people
understand that we're fighting we're
fighting it happens i yeah i uh
fractured my thumb in that last fight
bounced my hand off his head like 14
times in 15 seconds so it's bound to
happen were you were you aware that you
broke it when it happened right after
you knew right away oh right right after
that fight yes i i felt that right after
it was stopped and like it instantly got
swollen um but during
uh i didn't feel it cause the adrenaline
adrenaline i was just having too much
fun did you hit him on like on usually
like you break your hand or figure like
if it's up here it's like behind here i
couldn't dial in the right shot tim
thinks he sees it saw in the fight um or
in the replay where it was i don't
remember the exact shot usually i'm
pretty accurate and i can land on their
chin but
just one little mistake and i mean you
you break your thumb it's kind of the
only thing slowing you down though like
other than that yeah injury because
other than that you're kind of starching
dudes yeah that's i mean that's kind of
i said it before i was on the contender
series when i was going into the
contender series i said i have that it
thing i'm gonna come i'm gonna come in
the ufc and knock everybody out and blow
up and it's just kind of been that
mindset and that it's been happening i
thought the last guy like you talked
about this like not fighting
you know everyone's like oh we want to
see him fight a top five guy top ten you
know that's the fight world you know
yeah you know you want to see jake paul
fight canelo jesus christ man but
especially in the ufc
i think you're the one guy that the ufc
has done right by like not just after
you have all this
you know fan support and everyone see
you fight they're doing a good job with
you i'd like to get your perspective on
it but they're doing a good job where
they're not just toss you like right to
a title fight because it's a it's a
marathon not a sprint and we've seen
with other guys i can list some guys out
for you i don't call anybody out but
where they do catapult them right to the
top and they're not ready for it yet
like to me like your story like to come
up there's nothing better in the ufc
than the guys come up because once
you're there it's like yeah all right he
has millions of dollars and he's doing
the goddamn thing but the come-ups the
most fun for the fans so i think they're
they've you're the one guy they finally
got it right where they're not just
pushing you into these terrible
situations yeah and a lot of the ufc
fighters
they just they get almost
jealous is the right word or whatever
jealous would be the best i think i
think so too but also it's not it's not
just the ufc's like oh they can't just
pick a random person and build one up
like that you've got to have the
performances i'm having which i'm
knocking people out and i'm knocking
good guys out eddie weinland thomas
almeida like they're not maybe not their
prime or whatever but thomas mate is a
[ __ ] like he's [ __ ]
legitimate skills eddie weiner i could
say the same thing
um but for a title holly impaivo was
dude's a beast he's young he's 25 black
people it's like
it you know people like oh they're
giving them fights like you look at
paiva's record like he's no punk man i
think he had 20 something odd fights i
think was he 19 and two or something
like that like that's not like a walk in
the park right like to me
almost like the ufc didn't you give you
do you any favors give me that fight
like he's not a big name
really tough guy a lot of expanse you
started you know he wasn't ranked was it
right yeah a lot of people yeah i mean
i'm i have a lot of pressure on my
shoulders fighting guys that i'm
supposed to go out there and knock out
do you feel pressure i i in my heart in
my mind i'm confident i'm going to go
out there and knock them out so i
believe again i believe that but that's
it doesn't matter who i fight i'm going
to think that um
but it
it's not like it's not guaranteed
fighting is crazy it's not a guarantee
i'm gonna go out there and knock that
guy out if that fight went longer my
thumb could've been so bad i couldn't
have been using my right hand i could
have lost that fight and then it's not
like oh you fought a can it's like oh
you lost to nobody it's tricky it's a
tricky situation yeah i mean it's it's
it's fighting dude so anything can
happen but also
you know i think for you too like
there's just pressure on you but also
the cat's out of the bag like everybody
knows you're good yeah like it's not
like oh which is sugar and take him down
and submit like
i mean that's still kind of the
narrative
i think a lot of the people i mean they
i submitted talking origami i went eight
minutes with gilbert melendez like i can
grapple correct
but for whatever reason like that's not
a fight so it's different grappling jiu
jitsu and grappling fighting they are
different so i mean there is still the
narrative like
all you got to do is take them down put
them up because everyone's going to put
me up against the fence that's the first
thing and then try to take me down
putting me up against the fence is
harder than it sounds like a lot of
people like that's the goal put them up
against the fence
i'm juking up against the fence and then
you get hit with something you don't
really know where it's from but what i'm
saying cat's out of bag as far as your
striking abilities yeah like no one's
surprised that you're a good striker now
right like they're we we kind of expect
it yeah even though you're like
especially your last fight that was a
tough guy like we're we're expecting a
knockout right unfortunately that's
i don't want to say unfortunate but like
that's the narrative now yeah no i
definitely feel that kind of pressure
like i got to go out there and perform
but i don't feel like i have to change
my style or change my anything that's
i've been i've been fighting for 11
years and i've been doing the same thing
for 11 years i go out there and i knock
people out it's nothing that i have to i
don't do that i don't have like uh
that's just how i fight yeah it's your
style
you're not intending to do it it's just
that's your nature that's what happens
yeah when i fight yeah but also you've
been fighting for 11 years but how many
professional fights you have um
16. 16 which is a good amount a 15 and
oh and i've had 16 fights that's a
pretty good amount so you have
experience so i had 15 amateur fights
too which is a lot because my argument
was going to be like
let's say you're
the matchmaker for a day what do you do
with sugar shawn nets that's good
question you know there's the adrian
janice fight i think a lot of people
would love to see it's two young
strikers um and i look at adriana's as a
really good striker good i mean i think
he's a black belt jiu jitsu yeah he's
not ranked i don't care i've never cared
about rankings um you're right now
though
i'm ranked number 12 now
some people say number one and two
a lot of people say one or two
so there's the that fight the pedro uh
prelim pedro is an option dominant
cruise could be still an option um i
just i don't think cody's an option
right now just because
it's just low risk low or high high risk
low reward and i i heard you saying
because i love both you and cody so i
don't want you guys to fight i don't
have to pick because i love both of you
yes i've ride with both you guys
and i heard you say on full send shout
out to full send where it's like you're
like there's no upside to fighting cody
like he's lost whatever how many fights
you've been knocked out
miley caveat with that is
no matter what has happened for him in
his last five or six fights he's still a
former champ
veteran big name still ranked pretty
[ __ ] high no
they took him out of the rankings
he's not ranked he's not right oh wow
i'm pretty sure someone could check that
but yeah i don't think he's ranked and i
think my only caveat is with that it's
like
you know the the these guys that you
named before and besides dominic cruz
the hardcores and we know them your team
knows them those are badasses but as far
as like the narrative on you oh he's not
fighting anybody which is stupid to say
but let's just say if we wanted to
entertain he's not fighting buddy cody
is somebody not right you know what i'm
saying he's not he took him completely
out of the rankings so that definitely
doesn't make sense for you so my
argument's completely ruined well not
necessarily because i did say adriana's
who's not ranked but he's coming off a
win cody's lost six he's won one fight
since 2017 he's been knocked out i think
six times yeah and he just should have
won that last fight at 125 from kaikai
france who's five four i'm six six
brandon yeah you know what i mean oh
you're six eight and i'm six nines yeah
that's cool
yeah you're six six he just got knocked
out by a like kykar friend who i like
who's a stud who's super stunned but
he's dude but he also went down i i see
you're arguing with cody cutting down
first time to 125 you know what i'm
saying like yeah so the cut maybe had an
issue with it
and i'm not saying that the more we talk
about it's gonna make a lot of sense as
we keep going i was gonna pitch you on
that fight and your coach like no the
thing is still could happen i'm not
gonna say it's not going to i just like
that i guess the name recognition and i
do think it'd be a good fight he is a
hard hitter he clearly has skills yes i
don't see you guys fight because i love
both you guys but i get your argument
and i don't have one anymore
so if i mean if he would have won his
last fight makes all the still it's at
25 he won at 25 it makes more sense
but he'd probably fight again at 25 the
fact that he's coming off a loss at a
weight class below me now
i called him out three four fights ago
and he would he's kept saying no no dude
you called him out when we were doing
the companion i called him he was on the
companion you called him out like and
then
we don't have audio and then someone was
like hey he just called out cody and
cody's like let's [ __ ] do it and then
he goes to 25 which makes no sense to me
yeah so i just i don't see that fight
happening but it could potentially
happen
you never know but i guess because you
were saying that if they want you to
fight these bigger names you won't get
paid like so and i take that back i said
that probably three or four fights ago
now it's like
i have two more fights in my contract
i'm gonna fight who who they offer me
they offer me holly and private fought
him they offered me i'm i haven't and i
have this narrative that i'm picking
fights too you know they offered me
paiva i didn't go to the ufc so hey can
i fight piva they offered me pai but i
said yeah i didn't like that fight for
you and i didn't i didn't i i didn't
mind it i know he well he technically
was rank 15 when i got a fight yeah he's
a [ __ ] tough dude and not a big name
i just feel like young
i don't like it and going into that
fight i had bruised ribs i had i i was
that was a that was the most
mental
negativity i've dealt with going into a
fight i did very well and i was
confident going into it phenomenal but i
was i hadn't grappled in three weeks i
didn't spar in those last three weeks i
i hit mints and ran that's all i did
because i had bruised ribs and i didn't
in the back we were hitting myth i
didn't know if i could grapple yeah i
knew he was going to try to take me down
that's what every time i get into a
fight i'm like that's got to be their
goal to take me down they're not going
to strike with me so going in that fight
i was like [ __ ] this is going to be
this is like a big test mentally for me
well i feel like and before that you
find chris who's that mexican zombie
like you're just unloaded on them
but again to me being a fan and caring
about you like i like that you didn't
starch him in the first round yeah i
wanted to did start on the first round
you no you saved by the battle you lit
them up like a mexican pinata which is
fantastic but i like that you had to go
three rounds and be and you were able to
show off your skills and he kept coming
forward because it lets us know like if
you're our fan we can put you know stock
into you cause you're not gonna quit
you're not weakly weak minded you don't
have there's no cardio issues like all
right we got an actual contender here
where if you just start jump first round
starts them then you face a real tough
guy and you don't start you're like oh
how's sugar gonna do now we kind of know
right so i thought that was good the
fight before that i thought thomas i
made it was a it was a very different
fight it did go three rounds but it was
a very different pace completely
different like it was it was it was my
pace it was i hit him when i wanted to
he correct he couldn't close the gap
chris literally just kept walking
forward and eating shots the hardest
thing to do is thr is is
punch going backwards and i did that for
14 and a half minutes like i was
punching i was countering basically that
entire fight which i thought was good
for you it was as far as the progression
of your career i don't know how your
coach thinks of it but i thought i
thought it was a good i mean i thought
it was good learning now yeah it was a
good learning night but it's also just
complete dominance i was never in danger
no i was i was is anyone saying it was a
close fight no no no but it was just uh
but people expect you to start you know
oh yeah yeah yeah but i thought as far
as career longevity goes that was a good
outcome yeah but then you know when you
talk about how you're saying you're not
saying that how you know let's say they
give you dominick cruz well you're not
getting paid right now to at a dominant
cruise level and obviously he's been
around forever and he deserves it
more so any money they're paying off
right so if you take him on office he's
gonna pay discrepancy yeah and that's
another thing i wasn't really worried
about them offering me big big fights
right now because i'm not getting paid
big big money so therefore it's like but
dana did say i don't mean to rep danny
did say it's time to give that kid
a big fight and pay him go find anywhere
else
he's going to pay someone i agree so i
got i got two more fights and uh
i'm expecting a pretty good sized
contract and i it's not even like a lot
of the fighters say they want to get
paid like i feel like i truly deserve it
and for dana to acknowledge that it just
it shows oh i would cut that thing in
the meeting but can you remember this
yeah no i think and i think i have a
good relationship with the ufc and i
don't think it's going to be an issue
and i don't want to come down to like a
francis thing where francis is in the
media because i did i was in the media a
couple fights ago talk about money and i
don't want to be like that no you don't
want to be that way and also
to the ufc's defense which is rare i
argue with them
they're brilliant where i don't think a
lot of people figure this out the ufc
back in the day
they were a pay-per-view-based business
where they needed stars to sell
pay-per-view yeah that model is over so
whether francis fights sugar fights izzy
fights you name it
they don't care they just they're
filling fights for the the espn deal
so so they're they're not a star model
anymore right they're getting they're
not no matter what so if you or france
is like i'm out the ufc that's why you
don't see them really fighting for
people yeah okay cool we're still gonna
fill that card and make it happen yeah
so and i said this i'm not just saying
it's because you're here right now i
said this on the the shop show
take out conor mcgregor he's the outlier
yeah besides conor mcgregor you're the
most valuable person at the ufc yeah if
you look at your your you know you look
at your youtube following you your
podcast your merch your analytics when
it comes to twitch your your social
media relevance like for what they're
trying to do in the market they're
trying to go in there's nobody more
valuable to the company than you yeah i
appreciate that and i i selfishly or
humbly agree i i think i have the i
don't have to hear an argument if anyone
wants to argue your coach isn't going to
argue with me but i'd love to hear it
i've been i've been saying that i was
going to be in that position since
contender series which i think was seven
eight fights ago it's a long time to put
out performance after performance after
performance after performance um and
another random thing too is what i'm
kind of surprised with but not really is
peter and aljo our co-main event and
their main event pulls out so what do
they do they move the car they move them
correct they can't even do that they
can't even sell their own pay-per-view
and they're the bantamweight champion
both technically the bantamweight
champion right sucks it and they're
supposedly the best division in the ufc
yep and uh i think that's pretty
surprising um but i think what you've
done which fighters need to learn and
again people can hate on jake paul
especially and what he's doing but what
he's doing is showcasing to all you
fighters like listen man i'm not with
the ufc yeah i'm i built this on my own
so i'm capitalizing off my own fan base
and you you don't need this huge huge
organization to get things done and
that's how much money i'm making he's
pretty open about how much money he
makes so for you guys especially again
and like this isn't for everyone there's
about five five so you do it you're one
of the five
who where you know
hopefully you guys figure out the ufc
and you guys come to agreement it's a
great deal for you but if not now at
least you've seen a path in
jake paul
we can go down that route and make all
the money in the world yeah and that's
boxing specifically too i don't
i mean i guess you see habib coming out
with his own league his own league pfl
is like there's
there's like opportunities to make money
and others those aren't
see i'm not talking those aren't [ __ ]
you money no no no no no no no no no no
no i'm talking about [ __ ] you money
you're one of the guys who could do it
yeah where you could venture out where
if they don't want to play ball you're
one of the maybe a handful of guys nate
diaz connor you
francis can be able to do it if he wins
uh january 22nd there's there's only a
handful of guys who can do it but at
least that's why i like what jake paul
is doing he's shown you the value
of taking ownership but also to your
credit you've built it all like ufc was
like was it like hey make sure you dye
your hair dude make sure you wear this
dope [ __ ] jewelry make sure you do
this make sure you knock the guy out
make sure you have a dope ass twitch
like you've built all this yourself yeah
and i've also been like thankful to the
ufc that i had the opportunity because
my twitch instagram youtube none of that
would have grown without me knocking
people out in the ufc correct even if i
was knocking people on bellator like
they don't get as many eyes like none of
these get as much eyes so i had like the
reason i am popular is because of the
ufc like it's like it's a trade off
right it's a given people when they
complain about pay
at the same time too like ufc did give
you the stage and maybe they're not
paying you what you're worth but on the
back end of it you're smart enough
business man showing yourself with
brilliant guys where you you know you
have twitch you have your own merch and
you're doing all this other [ __ ] where
you have this additional income and
hopefully other fighters learn from that
and realize like there's a lot that if
you're just if you're waiting on the ufc
to make you this
you're you're going to be waiting
forever like you got to take control of
it a you got to win fights b you got to
win them pretty pretty convincingly and
then c you gotta also manufacture your
own hype man yeah winning fights doesn't
cut it not in the ufc you gotta you
gotta put on performances
i mean that that's that's where i really
do truly believe i was like the reason i
grew so fast was because the
performances the alfred shack in the my
first fight wasn't crazy against terry
on where my second fight had broke my
foot with three minutes left in the
fight still won the fight and then i
went on like the eddie weinland knockout
the jose quinones knockout
knocked out cheeto knocked out
um and you're six six i'm six nine yeah
you don't knock out yeah no but then
also if you think about two like it was
the perfect storm on that the uh tuesday
night contender series we get that crazy
knockout and snoop going viral like
posting none of that's by accident dude
like you've earned that like nothing was
given to you like you for you to get
that crazy knockout it just so happened
that you've been training for how
[ __ ] long and you prepared for the
moment just happens snoops there he
posts it goes viral and then you have
this dope look you have the personality
the charisma the skills not everyone can
do it yeah
don't give them too much good fun don't
give them too much no it's new posting
on social media after my last fight i
mean he still he still talks about sugar
shane doesn't ever talk about me but he
always he says sugar shane he's a fan of
sugar shane so i'll take it's close
enough he'll take it he's probably high
every time
every time
well let me feed you dude because you
don't how long were you thinking before
we eat how long you thinking you're out
what do you think um i got again crystal
ball i i go all right
uh when does sugar want to fight i'm
gonna usually i'm a three fight a year
kind of guy that's the goal i'm gonna
say two this year i'd like maybe july
and december fair point let me feed you
we can feed we need we can eat we can do
it
[Music]
you're no stranger to mexi man we're
both uh we just got mexican girls yeah
did your girl cook she cooked she she
doesn't she enjoys it when she cooks for
me but like if we're having a bunch of
people over she's not gonna be like what
i'm gonna cook so she like does it
because she knows i i'm like really into
what she could she's making like pisole
and taquito
not quite she doesn't she makes more
[ __ ] hamburgers when i want them okay
she's
makes a lot of salads especially in camp
my girl's specialty is their salsa oh
you will [ __ ] your pants oh god
hi hey how you doing
i'm great
[Music]
i'm going to do the chicken and avocado
quesadilla all right dude
pork before
and uh
yeah oh i bet those are fire too i don't
know i might just do that for now though
oh i bet that mole burrito is [ __ ]
fine dude mole i love mole damn mole
burrito i know dude
uh i gotta lose 10 pounds like the 29
for the thick ladder um i'm going to do
the
zopa decaying ball the ball
[Music]
let's take a little break from me
chatting sugar sean's air off before we
jump into this delicious mexican food
man
because we're eating food but you're
looking like they eat like trash but
they're in shape that's right because
we're on peloton man and peloton their
bikes the bike plus the ring the new
year with so much new new classes new
music new ways to keep your workouts fun
and motivating you're not doing the same
thing over and over all right the new
additions for the year you asked oh
that's funny weird they offer boxing yep
pelton's stepping into the ring with its
newest
discipline no gloves needed all right
discover a fast fierce fun workout with
peloton's instructors in your corner you
don't have to be a professional you
never have to box before these classes
are helped you to work up a sweat the
fundamentals footwork fun combos just
something different man if you're used
to always doing the same thing the new
artist series right music selection
pelton's adding fun new artists series
classes work out to music of single
artists from for an entire class which i
like to do uh or from your favorite hits
they got deep cuts you're talking about
pop rock hip hop edm they have over 100
artists series to choose from find your
favorite music turn your necks work out
into a freaking concert man
they have more variety it's easier to
stick to your goals when you keep the
workouts interesting and you're engaged
peloton has workouts for every goal day
mood de-stress from a long day with 30
minutes of strength 20 minutes of cardio
do a quick 15-minute total body class
all right before you head to work before
the kids come home super easy man all
right for limited time try pelton app
free for two months then it's just 12.99
a month after that new members only
visit onepeloton.com
app to learn more that's two months free
at o n e p a e l o t o n dot com offer
expires january 31st 2022 terms apply
you can find your boy on peloton my name
is thick prez
no i couldn't be a commentator i'm i'm
bi i'm biased on a phone i talked a lot
of [ __ ] about the commentating like dcf
but by then again i'm like i also said i
couldn't do it
but you you were critical of dc why but
here's my thing here's my thing with dc
so you know dc one of the greatest ever
do it personality
he if i think obviously and it became
like a trending thing for fighters to
[ __ ] on him like call him out for his
commentating yeah you know obviously
he's crushing it and he's very good at
it but he's also you know he's a fighter
man so he's having fun too yeah so i
think people got to realize like he's
not rogan he's not you know he's not
like john anak or dominick cruz who even
though don cruz is a fighter dominic
cruz i think does the best job
separating himself from the fighter and
being a he's a wizard as far as fighting
goes like knows the game inside and out
he's good at that but i think with dc
when you mix in personality and he's an
emotional dude in a good way you're
going to make some mistakes and you guys
got to give him that leeway no you have
an issue with what
they're there i've had an issue with his
company a couple quite a bit really yeah
i've been saying where you don't think
he's i don't know what it is maybe i'm
just going to be the puss but
i also do they sit there for three hours
watch fight after fight from the prelims
to the end of the fight so and i'm
usually at the end of the card you know
um so it's like he's been already
commenting for a while i don't remember
sometimes you when you you want more
enthusiasm
sometimes when he says like
for example a couple times i fight uh
because i watch my fights back quite a
bit sure
after the cheeto fight
cheeto lands up
one of the luckiest kicks on his his toe
lands on my perennial nerve okay so am i
going to my next fights and uh i fight
thomas almeida who's a great kickboxer
he's gonna try to kick my legs um
he tried to kick my legs a bunch and i
had i had the right answer i was pulling
out and i was checking i was returning
good answers i fight uh chris mentino
who did kick my legs quite a bit but
also i was countering you know switches
dances checking i was doing good and
then i fight paiva and i'm pretty he
says something like i don't know why
these guys don't try to just kick his
leg like cheeto did
i'm like dude i just fought thomas
almeida who tried to kick my legs up
[ __ ] and i just fought chris mountain
who did kick my legs what do you mean
you don't know why it's just these guys
just to defend him now granted he's
getting paid a lot of money to compete i
maybe that's like because you know think
how many fighters he has to cover right
so maybe that uh cheeto fight is in his
head and so he's bypassing with that
cheeto fight you go re-watch it and you
pull up the fights he didn't it wasn't
he wasn't doing a good job kicking my
legs
she literally kicked a sweet spot yes if
you want to say who kicked whose legs
that fight i kicked him and spun him in
a circle yeah i kicked his legs no
obviously it was there were better
technical calf kicks but his toe hit my
nerve so now it's oh i don't know how to
but for that was one instance another
thing is like oh he's looking at the
clock he's looking at the clock it's
like you don't want to know how much
time you got left
that last fight was perfect i look up at
the clock i know how much time i have
left 30 40 seconds whatever i i rock him
now okay do i make the decision to put
his to to empty my tank correct and try
to put him out or say okay i'm going to
save it i'm not going gonna have enough
he took but that's high level striking
that he didn't see agree but here's my
thing because he comes from the same
school of thought as i did back in the
day you're a different breed you're a
different breed but back in the so when
i saw you look at the clock i didn't go
oh man he's tired he's making sure you
know whatever i looked at like oh that's
a [ __ ] veteran movement he's trying
to see if he puts him out or not i was
with you on that in general though from
the the
the cloth that dc and i come from if you
look at like a wrestling wrestling yeah
woodley or somebody else when they would
look at the clock they want out man
they're trying out so maybe he's had so
many of that happen you know
which is exactly what the case is
correct so i mean that's the key in
wrestling you look at the clock coach
yells at you like what the hell are you
doing looking like so that's where he
was coming from so for me to go out
there and say that was just
just good banter do you get something to
talk about oh no i like dc
do i do i think
do i think he wants me to lose
i do why do you think that because i
remind him of jon jones shawn jones baby
i think that's what it is and i mean no
you have nothing in common besides a
long reach and a big dick
no i do think though i do think you're
sick i think you were just satisfied
seeing me lose i do not i disagree and i
bet dc reaches out to you i disagree i
think you have that like
to get to your level i think you have to
have chips on your shoulder and feel
that way and that's fine and that's if
that motivates you great but i i don't
think dc has like any ill will towards
you like because the better you do
the better it is for everybody the more
eyeballs because
again if sugar sham would go on a three
fight [ __ ] losing streak it'd be a
it'd be terrible yeah no i definitely
like i'm it's good bathroom dc i like it
but it's also ufc is a male soap opera
you know so like any of that stuff gets
traction when it's really not a big deal
yeah i'm not trying to pick b for dc
because in reality he'd [ __ ] kill me
so these are facts yeah some guys call
him out and i'm like really you know he
could do i know he looks out of shape
he's built like a hippo but yeah he's
definitely fatter you feel like a baby
yeah still skills i mean dude he's one
of yeah one of the greatest of all times
yeah hands down now i heard and if i
went and commentated one ufc fight i bet
people would be like what the [ __ ] you
sound like an idiot i guarantee i'd say
some [ __ ] that was like what nah you're
doing yourself a dis disservice and
that's why i want you on fight campaign
i think you'd be entertaining as [ __ ] i
would try it yeah because i everything
you do is pretty entertaining so i think
if you did decide to go that route like
never say never yeah i think it would be
pretty fun if i did a commentating thing
well i'd do the fight companion for sure
but if i was to after my career do
whatever
um commentating you'd have to be
something where you could say you could
cuss just openly yeah i don't know if i
can do it dude like espn oh i guess
pay-per-views joe does he cuss i mean a
little bit but still the espn before the
pay-per-views would be [ __ ] tough i
agree no yeah by the way part of the
party oh if someone's like hey you can't
cuss i wouldn't have a job yeah i cuss
all the time me [ __ ] dude
yeah i mean
like if
you know like some comics do those
corporate gigs and they ask me doing
like
and they're like we can't cuss me i'm
out like i don't have a career if i
can't dude that's one thing that would
be so hard would be stand-up comedy or
even like a live podcast because
like when we were flying here i told tim
i was like all right we're going to our
first live podcast in l.a just joking
around but be tough
live podcast would be as tough as
stand-up comedy i like to think of
myself as a comedian i'm pretty sure it
says in my instagram bio like i think
that's where hilarious thank you i think
that's where uh
that's where the views are like comedy
but stand up would be so [ __ ] hard
like writing a joke would be hard but
delivering it
it would be so difficult the toughest
part about stand up is like let's say
you were you and your coach were
training a move that was like dope in
the gym and you're pulling off pulling
off and you're doing a fight and it just
beats [ __ ] on your back and then you
just got to keep doing it until you make
it work and there's only one way to do
it is by doing it live when everybody's
watching that's why stand-up stuff
yeah no that's definitely one of the
toughest things toughest thing but as
far as live podcasts like you know have
you done broken yet
i think i'm the youngest i think i was
22 or 23 i think i was the youngest
person to ever be on rogue so back in
the day yeah i was right after i fought
andre soccer mom broke my foot so that
was when
so that was so that was when um he was
live he was on spotify right correct
because his shows used to be live so
like the i think it was i don't think it
was live in live but it was before the
spotify it was like in that little pro
little time where it was fight
companions we used to i mean we do fight
plans live here but then we do i mean
the original fight campaign was calling
eddie broken we were live and dude we
got hammered and then we would get out
and we wouldn't remember what we said
the next day we'd look at the headlines
like you know shop calls female fighter
a [ __ ] i'm like oh no dude i didn't
mean that like i'm with the boys i
didn't think anybody was listening boy
talk yeah can get you trouble you got to
be careful if you know you're live too
it's like
you know you're a little more censored
right but that's where the liquor helps
out see or doesn't help
[ __ ] i know i'm saying it helps out
because then you're just like ah
yeah yeah you know i i've been after
that last fight against chris so two
fights ago that went on like every
weekend like eight weekends in a row we
were going to miami la texas like we
were going out every weekend drinking it
was [ __ ] fun but alcohol is a
[ __ ] i haven't drank i drank
after my last fight
uh the night that night and then i think
i got drank uh yeah i drank one more
time since then so i haven't been
drinking as long as you don't have one
as long as you don't have a problem yeah
i love it i don't like [ __ ] i would have
a drink right now you know what i'm
saying and you don't have a fight
someone get that tiger thinking i mean i
would take
yeah i plan on uh i definitely don't
have a problem i don't have a problem i
can control i can turn on and off at a
problem during the pandemic there's
nothing to do whatever but um
yeah it's tough but
so yeah so after your fights i think
this is what else kind of builds
everything you're doing
like your life looks like granted it's
instagram and stuff like that but your
life looks as fun as your hairstyle
because
you're with takashi six nine you're with
you know by our boy bradley martin
you're like jet setting and all this
[ __ ]
how i mean how do you even get in that
world as far like takashi six nine like
that's random yeah did you guys get did
you get tattoos together yeah which one
hit the six nine tab he tattooed on me
well part of it and did he get
no he should have got a sugar tap yeah
yeah yeah
so i met him from steve steve will do it
uh after that last fight when i fought
green hair uh chris i flew out to miami
and he's like hey you wanna hang out
with six nine i'm like [ __ ] yeah dude i
love bumping six like me too i'm bump
sticking all the [ __ ] time yeah and
uh so we met up with six and he's just a
normal [ __ ] good dude yeah i mean i
what are we talking about here
you can only know someone so well when
you you know hang out and we go get
drunk you know like we hung out sober
good dude good conversation you know but
the first i we asked him or tim asked
him like when was the first time you saw
me fight and it was when i did the
rainbow hair the first time i did my
hair when i fought eddie weinland oh
he's like someone's like hey you gotta
see this and like that was that hair was
inspired obviously from there was the
rainbow hairs six nine hair dope um but
yeah that was that was cool so that's
how i got in with six and a good dude
like will you text now with six nine i
talked to him the other day because we
asked him were you asking if we wanted
to be on the pod and do a zoom call and
he's like [ __ ] zoom it's like yeah
you're right it would be a better it
would be a better zoom i would be a
better pod like we just got to flatten
out you could fly you know [ __ ]
dude down there yeah yeah so i want to
do you know so i'd text him the other
day we talked here and there but
um and he's got some [ __ ] sweet sweet
collabs coming out music wise yeah i'm a
fan of him i think the narrative on him
like being a snitch i don't know where
you stay on that but when i look more
into it you know you look at his gang
affiliation stuff like that see i don't
even i don't even go that far i'm like i
love his music that's my though i'm jam
out i don't know i like that i listen to
his music in the gym and then also when
people hate them for being a sis stuff
like that it's like i think i would
snitch too if i was in a city if yeah
they're you know what i'm saying like
baby mama and stuff yeah supposedly i
heard you let's go away for life and
like if you're just telling some people
man you're going to be out like uh
where's your paper at yeah like get me
the [ __ ] out of here no i thought he was
a good dude kidnapped me and threatened
to kill me so yeah give me the [ __ ]
paper so i don't put it too much on him
but other than that like my actual real
life dude that's like those are random
those are rare things that happen after
the fight i'm saying that's insane
that's not my life i mean it is it does
look like i'm doing it like it looks
[ __ ] lit though but my life is is
well not training right now because i
haven't been able to because my cast i
just got it off but dude it's i live in
peoria [ __ ] arizona dude like i live
in the suburbs it's like old like it's
like a more
calm slow slow place it's not like
scottsdale
i couldn't live there dude i i know
chicks dude
there's no there might be i haven't met
him and peoria there's not a lot of hot
chicks out there
uh airbnb rental that means my brother
owned out there and oh really yeah well
that's gonna play it's funny because i'm
flying out
um i'm flying out a couple twitch
subscribers and two of them are actually
cuz i have an apartment where i game at
like right across the street from my
house and uh i have two two kids from
twitch moving in they're gonna live
there oh no i met him once they they
flew down before they fought and i had
like a twitch [ __ ] fight card so they
fought in my cage yeah and it was funny
but anyway they're coming down i just
bought a limo like a 2000 lincoln limo
so we can all cruise around together but
i'm bringing them out to scottsdale so
i've only partied in scottsdale maybe a
couple times it's fantastic not recently
so i'm pumped but we're gonna bring them
out when is that uh end of january okay
it's gonna be [ __ ] funny but yeah
we're gonna be cruising what's the plan
with the twitch kids like you're
starting like your own sugar network i'm
just what are we talking about
they're just i'm help trying to help
them get there you know they're they
started their own podcast you know the
the the brandon schmidty show they get
800 views you know they're like growing
a little bit so i'm just helping them
come out
and just helping them [ __ ] get going
they both live with their parents i
think schmidt he's 29 29 i'm just
helping them get going they're good
dudes they're [ __ ] creative they want
to work hard and you know i told them i
said well you know i said you got to
come you got to come out get a job don't
rely on me you're going to do your own
[ __ ] but
i'm i'm getting very busy i might need
something but they should be under the
sugar
llc yeah i mean we're gonna i want them
to make sure that they're gonna come out
and just kind of they know that they're
secure and they're gonna have their own
money but realistically like
the shine with the shine base the rub
off sugar is what's gonna really help
them oh yeah of course but i don't know
how we don't get sugar on their thick
boy dude what do you mean the thing we
could do i'm i i'm very uh open-minded
yeah
i love business dude it's something
that's super super fun this is what i
want to talk about on or out we can do
it here but you're talking about the
marijuana strain yeah how yeah have
people approach a lot
and because
also i don't get how the diaz brothers
don't make [ __ ] you money off their own
marriage
well i kind of went on that you should
too you like you should do
so you're talking a guy who started his
own whiskey and when i started my own
wisdom
i was like oh i'll just i make it and i
sell it yeah and then they're like nah
[ __ ] the way it works you need
distributors and those the sales team
they've been selling buffalo trades for
200 years and then you just expect them
to hustle your stuff for what so it's
like these relationships and getting to
certain cities and you don't launch
nationwide you do what we're doing in
february you do texas florida denver
cali new york you see how it goes then
you branch out so it's it's like how
happy dad did it right yeah there you do
there you go but then with marijuana
like it's not legal everywhere yeah
that's what makes it so tricky that's
why nick and nate are making [ __ ]
money that's why i don't have a strain
right now ah there's so much that goes
in someone's gonna listen to this and
because here's the thing about marijuana
there's so much money to be made in it
you have legit like and they're not they
don't you they probably smoke weed but
you have legit business entrepreneurs
who have made a hundred million dollars
in whatever their business now they're
in the marijuana business right and they
look at you like well this kid's a
[ __ ] walking gold mine yeah
and all you should be is the face of it
but you should have equity in the
company yeah and then that's your own
[ __ ] no i i plan on that being my
hundred million dollar business that's
your [ __ ] that's that's gonna be my
[ __ ] money and it's it i know what's
to happen just like because we've done a
strain before and then it kind of just
there's so much logistics that goes into
it moving from state to state and like
if it's a seed or or if it's the flower
itself there's just a lot but you're
going to i'm telling you this now you're
going to partner with somebody who they
have all that figured out yeah all you
got to do is promote it and you have
equity in it and then you're going to
get [ __ ]
[ __ ] you money yeah if you found out how
much mike tyson makes off his string
you'd go [ __ ] rightfully so too yes
mike [ __ ] tyson yes i've never met
him yet you haven't done the uh i got
how about we we haven't had we haven't
it hasn't worked out yet i'll cut up i
mean i'll connect you guys
i remember listening to his book because
i uh
like every time we camp i like listening
to uh i i listened to michael jordan
book when i was watching last dance i
think a couple fights ago i listened to
mike tyson book dude his story tyson's
has got to be the craziest [ __ ] story
of all time the amount of chicks he was
[ __ ] raw dogging not giving a [ __ ]
fantastic dude i got me out i was just
in bed like wow think about the hero
back in the day just the king of the
world
and just slang and dick dudes i'm going
to prison i hear you but um
he's such an interesting dude because
there's this thing about him like i've
done hop boxing i co-hosted hot boxing
with him and francis ingano
and you have francis there
and mike's been on food truck daddy's
been on this show
and growing up and you're young me but
you know like the legend of mike tyson
like how scary he was
but then everyone was like dude he's so
friendly now he's a changed person but
you know how like when you see like a
pit bull that you got and they're like
all beefing like he's really friendly
with kids you're like okay you know like
with tyson it's like that same vibe like
he's a good he's such a good person he's
worked on himself so much and you love
him but you can [ __ ] see him in his
eyes man if [ __ ] pops off everybody's
[ __ ] yeah and he's one bad strain away
from [ __ ] twisting everybody's head
off and i was like nervous like it's
hard it's hard to make me nervous
i'm just gonna take this [ __ ] guy
down right
he pops up
i'm like looking at his boys i'm like
all right he's old he's not gonna do
[ __ ] he's old i'm here with [ __ ]
three hipsters so i'm gonna take him
down as long as i get tyson
i'm good yeah but you can tell it's that
those demons are embedded in his [ __ ]
soul but like you said he's not you can
tell he's done a lot of work i mean
although the toad the toads definitely
helped his ayahuasca trips and stuff
you're [ __ ] totes i haven't i've
never done any of the toaster alaska i'm
you look like i'm talking with
mushrooms i've never done the toads
though i've uh now do you lick the toad
or are we talking about drops on the
tongue anybody done in here i don't know
tim [ __ ] the toads that's totally
different that makes sense tim has some
nfd toads that's fine no tim's a good
tim's a good dude because he'll if
you're out with with the boys and you're
you find a little you find a chick and
she's hot she's got a fat friend
no
he jumps on the grenade you know
not even if i have to dude hold up let
me get this straight coach and grenade
hopper do what a [ __ ] legend
but does tim have to like when you're
like out with the cash design or
something like that yeah he's right
there yeah he's with i see him with you
all the time i [ __ ] love him he's a
monster right i don't think he gets
enough recognition for what he's done
with you but anyway
i'll get off his dick but the thing is
is
he's still your coach so when you're
like in miami getting laid doing takashi
69 trying to tattoo his dick on your
face whatever are you trying to like you
see like hey man like it's getting a
little too hostile let's get out of here
like does he ever do does he ever do
never i mean there's sometimes where's
tim the guy like yeah talk to my face
neither if it's 3 30 and i'm it was like
he's like all right we got a [ __ ]
like photo shoot at 9am let's go home
he's that guy but it's not like hey dude
you need to [ __ ] chill i'm always
pretty like there's been times i get way
too drunk but in the for the most part
like when it comes to training hey you
need to be here you need to do this i
don't need anyone tell me that i don't
need someone to tell me hey you should
probably do you're
like i don't really need that i'm i'm
i'm there
i show up and i do what i need what
needs to be done no you're professional
levels which this brings my next subject
my boy todd feldman he's like the head
king at ca
he loves you and he he's super into like
body optimization like getting the full
performance out of the body and he was
listening to talk about sleep
and i think you got the the ring on i
said i'm the best sleeper in the ufc i
dude i'll get to that i'll get to that
ring thing i have issues with the ring
thing but um he was saying that he was
like it's i think what's the narrative
on sugar shot off the sugar chain
obviously the way he looks obviously the
way he looks
and you wouldn't think like you think he
just like walks in the gym does his
thing and you know he's not like that
professional athlete but when you hear
him talk he talks about his sleep and
stuff like that
so you i mean
your hair's crazy you know
you had chains and tattoos and stuff but
you're actually pretty conscious of your
health yeah i think um
i'm very conscious like the first time i
listened to matthew walker and joe rogan
changed my sleep forever that was like
he's a sleep doctor did you make it
through the whole podcast
yeah i make it through all the sleep
dude i make it through a lot of trouble
i'm like it's the last one i've probably
stolen eight of them but anyway i
listened that that changed my sleep
forever um
it's the number one performance enhancer
ever like you go and train hard and eat
good but you don't sleep good you're not
gonna get out of it you go hard you go
you have like a good training session
but you don't eat good but you sleep
decent like it's not the same i'm
training good smart
not over training eating good perfect
diet in camp nutritionist blood get my
blood done and i'm sleeping good i'm
[ __ ] i'm dialed in and i think my
performances show that i agree you don't
go and have performance at the
performance at their performance like
i'm doing without everything dialed in
and with the sleep like whether those
called the sleepers
or a ring yeah so my brother wears all
the time he wears that in his wedding
ring looks like chris angel
all the time too much rings but
with my i wore it for like a month what
i didn't like about it especially as a
fighter like
i'm sure your coach can attest to this
like some days you're not gonna feel
good but if i have a app that goes take
it easy today i'm like [ __ ] i got i'm
shark tank today i got eight rounds with
these world-class dudes so that would
get in my mind like even though i wasn't
training you'd be like take today off
i'm like dude i have three shows two
stand-ups at night and and i gotta train
and then i gotta pick up my you know
what i'm saying so i'm like it can be a
mental [ __ ] for sure i feel like i have
it so dialed in that if i know i'm
sparring saturday like that's gonna
change what i'm doing friday because i
know i have to you know have good rounds
saturday but i just have camp such
[ __ ] dialed in
you know i that it doesn't [ __ ] with me
and my sleeps
like i said i have some of the best oh
yeah i want to tell you that dude i said
but in in the interview before the fight
like fight week i said i have the best
sleep in the ufc
like couple hours later i'm like [ __ ] i
shouldn't have said that i'm gonna be a
meme dude i'm gonna be a [ __ ] period
i'm gonna get knocked out and i'm gonna
be it's gonna say that like i thought
for sure that was gonna be be
i i really should have said that but no
sleep is kind of like uh the secret
performance enhancer a lot of people
don't think about 100 to anything you
want to be a better stand-up you want to
be a better [ __ ]
anything not even physical if you want
to be a better [ __ ] teacher or
professor [ __ ] of anything sleep's
gonna be a hundred percent dude there's
a hype for a little bit where like i
think it was like pete did he was like i
only sleep four hours and i was like
yeah i'm gonna try that
no i in it yeah and i would have never i
would have never learned about if i
didn't listen to that podcast that
podcast changed my life a lot of joe's
podcasts do too for sure uh my boy's at
suplex i think he's at supalex sneakers
on instagram
i went to them because they're they're
my shoe plug right i have all the shoes
in the wood so they're my shoe plate i'm
like hey for the fighters i have on i
want to give them a shoe that represents
them and they're like say less they're
like what do you want to do for sugar so
i came up with this idea i'm like can
you find can you source this shoe like
we'll find it
so shout out to uh suplex sneakers
they're in philly but as far as any hard
shoe to get any shoe in general they're
the best in the world my boy mike
monster down there is a pet fox whatever
so these are the shoes i selected for
you they're the jordan one jay balvins
they're the most
yes they're the most
unique jordan ones like so the jordan
one silhouette has been done a million
times they do all these collabs
and these are the most unique and loud
ones and to me these represent you
because you got to be the most unique
guy in the ufc so these jordan ones
represent you my man dude
i feel like they're right up your alley
man and takashi 69 it's gonna be all
over these
they're [ __ ] fire
i don't i don't have myself but they're
[ __ ] dude these are the sickest
[ __ ] shoes i've ever seen i love that
pink
i mean
is that not a sugar issue sick issue
ever yes they're so simple not easy to
get but you kind of appreciate them no
problem
yeah thanks for doing the show man so
dope
yeah aren't they dope
oh yeah these are [ __ ] brenda i'm a
fan of j balvin too yeah they got the
smiley face in them dude
they got all the crazy colors they're
the most unique jordan of all time dude
yeah those are nuts but those are from
me and my friends at suplex and philly
dude yes thank you guys hopefully you
rock them of course because you're
careful rocking these bad boy you don't
want to step on these yeah you don't get
robbed either hollywood's getting a
little dicey man oh dude the difference
yeah
those are you in a nutshell brother i
appreciate it yeah you got it brother
super sick
dude that's no no those represent you
dog so hopefully you wear them oh don't
be the guy who just puts them on the
shelf or something okay i'm already i'm
already thinking of ideas with uh i got
dope it's my suitcase
[Music]
uh they're in philly billy but they're
you know they're worldwide you'll see
them on uh
[Music]
yeah man so i can't thank you enough
yeah i always support you you crush this
as usual you're the first guest since i
left showtime to be on food truck diary
i hit you up like dude
my team's running on this on think boy
now i need a big guess you said say less
yes and a fight companion one uh
calabasas
i want to come down and do that dude
thank you so much yeah i really
appreciate that that was [ __ ] heal up
tell your boy takashi 69 what's up
hopefully enjoyed the food and uh yeah
man appreciate you do it yeah thank you
sugar everybody thanks for doing it
brother dude these are [ __ ]
sick big super thick from my wallet
[Music]
i need everything i get super thick boy
you